حسنًا، كشف الجيش الإسرائيلي يوم الأحد عن مقطع
فيديو جديد لما
يسميه أكبر نفق لحماس
اكتشفه داخل قطاع غزة
في الماضي، وقد رأينا أنفاق
اكتشفها الجيش الإسرائيلي
حيث يتعين على الأفراد السير في
صف واحد من أجل ذلك  للمرور عبرها بشكل
ضيق للغاية ولكن هذا الممر واسع جدًا
في الواقع واسع بما يكفي لقيادة
مركبة كبيرة من خلاله وفقًا
للجيش الإسرائيلي، يصل عمقه إلى 50 مترًا
تحت الأرض وهو مجهز بكل
شيء بدءًا من الكهرباء وحتى
أنظمة التهوية والاتصالات
العسكرية الإسرائيلية  يقول إنه
جزء من شبكة أوسع من الأنفاق
تمتد لمسافة ميلين ونصف ميل أو حوالي 4
كيلومترات، ولم يعبر هذا النفق فعليًا
إلى داخل إسرائيل ولكن يبدو أنه تم
استخدامه من قبل حماس داخل قطاع غزة
وهو قريب جدًا  إلى أحد
المعابر الرئيسية بين إسرائيل
وغزة وهو معبر آر إس
والذي كان أيضًا موقعًا رئيسيًا
هاجمه مسلحو حماس في 7 أكتوبر
ثم عبروا إلى إسرائيل أه من هناك
لا يوجد حتى هذه اللحظة أن
هذا النفق تم استخدامه  جزء من أه
هجوم 7 أكتوبر لكن حجم وحجم
نفق الأنفاق هذا يظهر فقط
قدرة حماس على بناء
هذه الشبكات الكبيرة من الأنفاق التي
تقول حماس أن هناك مئات
الأميال تحتها من غزة جيريمي دايموند سي إن إن
تل أبيب